hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll this
is kind of an obvious thing to say but
cities play an increasingly important
role in the modern world we've talked
about cities a few times on mindscape
we talked to will wilkinson about the
relationship between urban versus rural
and political partisanship we talked to
joe walston about the environmental
impacts of cities which are largely
positive concentrating all of the people
and their products and resources in a
tiny area but the cities themselves we
haven't talked about that much the
growth of a city the shape of a city the
un estimates that by 2050 more than
two-thirds of the global population will
live in cities so understanding how they
grow how they form how their shape
becomes what it is is very important and
by the shape i don't just mean the shape
of the boundary of the city limits right
inside the city there is structure the
central core downtown area might have a
different mix of residential and
businesses and manufacturing than the
outer periphery does
and what i like about this question is
it's a wonderful example of the
differences between top-down and
bottom-up ways of making a complex
system because in some sense the natural
growth of a city is completely organic
right you have people they want to buy
some land build something put up some
way of living together in some
complicated fashion but then you have to
also have some planning you have to have
sewers you have to have streets you have
to have transportation and so forth and
sometimes you get very ambitious kinds
of planning where you plan out a whole
city from the start and inevitably those
planned cities don't quite look natural
in some way so today's guest is
catherine brinkley who is an ecologist
and urban scientist who really has
thought very carefully about what a city
is how cities grow and what kinds of
shapes they have and for what reasons it
is very much sort of urban studies as a
physics problem it's made of individual
people and those people feel pushes and
pulls and basically they're kind of
searching for an equilibrium where they
can all settle down and be happy so why
do cities take the shapes that they do
how do they grow and get bigger and how
should they grow and get bigger because
in that set of many many people all of
whom have interests and ideas about how
things should go not everyone might
benefit from every single idea so how do
we build cities that are not just a
place to live but a good place to live a
place where you would be happy to live
given that we human beings like a little
bit of green space and outdoor time not
just a few square feet in which to house
ourselves so there's an important and
interesting conversation that goes in
all sorts of areas you know unlike the
usual physics conversation you have to
bring in ideas from very many different
fields to think about cities and how
they grow and like i said it's important
even if you don't live in a city many
other people do our world is governed by
mostly people who live in cities for
better or for worse so we want that to
be good for the people who live there
and for the people who don't so let's go
[Music]
catherine brinkley welcome to the
mindscape podcast i am so honored to be
here
i want to talk about the science of
cities this is something you work on
something you've written about but i
thought it'd be fun to just
ease our way in by starting with the
romance of cities or you know the way
that we feel about the idea of a city
it's clearly a resonant concept that has
different kinds of connotations for
different people right there's the idea
that it's sort of exciting in the city
and cosmopolitan and sophisticated but
also the idea that maybe it's a little
bit less authentic you know the
heartland and the rural areas are more
real america presumably other countries
feel the same way i don't know what is
what is your feeling about how we should
think about the whole phenomenon of a
city from a more emotional point of view
i think you're right that people think
about it in so many different ways there
are so many analogies for the city from
people talking about cities as if they
are slime molds just
eeking out into the rural area and
sucking up nutrients uh jane jacobs
famously wrote that cities are the
wealth of nations and that the sidewalk
is like a ballet so lots of beautiful
imagery there i like to think of cities
as coral reefs these incredibly complex
structures that are diverse that are
responding to their environments
growing changing but also very
vulnerable
to some of the same things that coral
reefs are vulnerable to like climate
change
right um
and then others boil a city down to
thinking of it as just a cell so a
simple simple cell simple organism they
are far from simple but sometimes those
analogies are really useful if you're
trying to simplify the study of cities
well it brings up something i was going
to get to later but i might as well hit
it right now which is the idea of a city
as a complex system right i mean the
idea that if we can analogize it to
coral reefs or to cells there must be
some common properties between all these
different ways to be a complex system
yes and
and that has formed the basis of
a lot of shared research in human
ecology thinking about
the ecology of cities uh the rank size
order of cities
trying to take this incredibly complex
feature
and
boil some some simple facts out of it
and because so whether you live in a
rural area or an urban area you are
impacted by the city whether you
are drawn to it because you need to work
there or
where you live there and you love going
to the theater you know it's
the city touches all of us uh you know
some of us try and run away others run
towards it
right but it exerts an effect one way or
the other and i think more people are
running toward right like did i was it
in your paper i saw this statistic from
the un the two-thirds of people are
going to be living in cities before too
long
yes this is the
the u.n is has been touting
the
rise of cities as more and more people
are moving to cities for jobs and
as a result of that
there has been
an expansion of the urban footprint but
the urban print is such a small
small footprint compared to
agricultural land
so the urban footprint is about three
percent of um
of the land area compared to
the agricultural uh footprint which is
about 30 sometimes 40 percent depending
on how you count so it's it's still a
small footprint but because there are so
many people moving to cities and when
they move to cities they
walk more bike more there's less
sewer
line laid per capita
there there's uh some uh
economies of scale to be had uh and and
there's a lot of hopes planned on
reducing greenhouse gas emissions as
more people move to cities
yeah this is definitely a message i've
gotten in a couple of different podcasts
i've done with joe walston and jeffrey
west i think a lot of people
think about a city they see all the
concrete all the electricity all the
cars and they see energy and consumption
in something that is not natural but
per capita all this consumption is
relatively less right i mean cities are
really much kinder to the overall
environment uh than other ways of living
is that is that a correct impression
i think it's a debated impression on the
one hand there's less uh as i mentioned
sewer or concrete laid per capita but on
the other hand there are these
vast networks of resources that cities
suck up
in terms of energy in terms of
water and food and so there's a whole
literature on teleconnections with
cities that
problematizes that our city is really
good for the environment
okay perhaps not as good as we like to
say they are and then on the flip side
as much as people are moving to cities
anyone who's been to a city knows that
they are not optimized systems there are
neighborhoods that are very much
struggling there are sections of the
city which are losing population so it's
not it's not a
it's not a total
it's a total sum growth but it's not all
the parts that are that are equally
growing and there are cities that are
shrinking too sure um globally so it's
it's a it's a complicated picture well i
think that's perfectly fine i'm glad
that you're here to to help us
understand the complications because i
i'm not not my area i will
uh simplify things a little bit but but
you're completely right about those
dependencies i remember living here in
los angeles being struck by
learning about how bad earthquakes would
be not because buildings would fall down
because we're pretty good at building
buildings that are not going to fall
down an earthquake but because all
connection to water and power would be
shorn uh if the san andreas fault does
anything terrible then la would just be
kind of plunged back into the middle
ages pretty quickly
yeah
and that that's kind of the scary thing
with a lot of the
climate models that are predicting
extreme weather events cities
many of them are in coastal areas that
are in the direct path of potential
disaster and and like coral reefs very
very vulnerable
to that so there's this dual need to
think about how to adapt and also how to
mitigate and we have excellent models
for predicting where we will experience
more extreme weather events we have
excellent models for the policies we
perhaps should adopt to reduce emissions
or to
uh
adapt
but we don't have is a really good grasp
on what we're actually doing
and this is where my field planning
comes in and there is a lot of work to
be done in terms of how we plan cities
how we're planning for these futures and
part of that is that
jane jacobs and many others worked very
hard to move city planning from a
top-down
experts are telling you how to develop
cities towards a bottom-up
justice social justice oriented version
of how to plan cities where you're you
are talking to
housewives about how they get their kids
to school and you're talking to cyclists
about how they safely navigate through
the city and you're reflecting that back
in the plan
but one of the the problems with the way
that we do planning is that a lot of
plans that are made are then put on the
shelf and there's a real need to
aggregate all of that data what cities
are planning to do in terms of where
they're building housing
roads
read those plans which are thousands of
pages long
and and then demonstrate how we're going
to meet these challenges
well this is great because it leads
right back to this
cities as a complex system kind of
question i mean real world complex
systems whether they're coral reefs or
cells
uh have this kind of fractal structure
right they're kind of heterogeneous
there's different sub-things doing
different things
and
planned cities seem very different to me
than unplanned cities i know you're
talking about planning within the life
of an organic already existing city but
especially in asia and other places
there are experiments now where we're
just building a city from scratch right
building this this huge thing and and
i'm struck by like the different ways
that roads are laid out in a square grid
versus something more organic and
vibrant i mean how how plausible is it
that a puny human mind can plan a
successful city all by itself
there are a lot of indicators that that
an emergent model of planning cities
works out better in terms of considering
uh equity issues and a lot of the cities
that were planned in top-down
fashions uh as jeffrey west i think
talked about on your podcast as well
have ended up not keeping that form
and have major major traffic issues
there are cities that have been planned
um
to have a particular form and it's
worked out really well so an example of
that is copenhagen's finger plan where
it's got a five-finger plan with
copenhagen in the palm and then a
high-speed transit
rail out on the fingers and that that
plan which was set uh in the 50s
has
worked you still see these green wedges
uh of protected farmland and um
and then urban areas and the fingers
have gotten a little short and fat at
this point in time but but it's a plan
that worked and
i think that part of the reason that
plan has worked is
there is this
dual
ism in terms of wanting the urban life
but also wanting access to green space
and this gets at the heart of
what has perhaps not worked with a lot
of urban theories about city building
and uh
how we need to do city building
differently to think about green space
and urban space
it in the same breath so that we're not
building an urban theory that's only
science of cities but it's science of
cities plus
green space plus food systems and i mean
forgive me if this is just hubristic on
my part as a physicist but i tend to
think of some of this as
thinking of cities as physics systems
right where people and resources and
things like that all have interactions
some of them attract some of them repel
and we search for an equilibrium and the
equilibrium might have to sort of be
found naturally rather than imposed from
above is that a useful kind of
metaphorical way of thinking or is that
just my simple-minded way of
squeezing urban planning into my own
focus no i think i think that's a good
way of thinking about it but just like
in in physics uh
everything is connected
so june jordan who's a who's a
an urbanist in the 1960s has this
beautiful short poem
on bell's theorem which states that we
can't fall apart
there are no parts
oh i like that you need to email me that
poem i'll put it we'll put a link to it
in the in the show notes that's very
good
uh okay yes i mean of course quantum
mechanics areas of physics are a little
bit harder i mean that
i i am well aware that that could be an
analogy that is pushed further than it
should be but okay but yeah statistical
classical mechanics might might make
sense and so so good let's get into the
nitty-gritty a little bit about what
those forces are uh that that work in in
shaping uh how cities look etc so
apparently this goes way back right i
mean there are people
more than a century ago were thinking
about why there's central concentrations
in cities and what kind of characters
they take on
it goes back even further than that
aristotle was openly questioning how big
should a city get
um
and and
making statements in awe and wonderment
that you could conquer the city of
babylon and it took some neighborhoods
three days to find out that their city
had been conquered it just took that
long for the information to percolate
and that those
theories helped
inform
where you put city walls what should the
city walls encompass farms how big
should the city get should you have
multiple cities
um
and and then of course some of the the
real theory building in the 1800s with
heinrich von thunen who
first notice to the bid rent curve which
is this idea that if a lot of people
stand together on the same land or build
houses in an urban area it changes the
value of the land under their feet and
when you change the value of the land
you have to change how you use the land
in order to meet rents so
around that urban area you would have
the first zone would be dairy because
you could make more money off of dairy
so you could pay your rent and then the
next zone would be crop and then further
out into the distance would be forest
where
you had a longer timeline to to recoup
your
your value and this um
this model
was very focused on the outside of the
city so how the city re was changing the
land uses
around it and that that model has been
tested it was tested in the 70s
by by a scholar the last name heart who
noticed that as cities grow they create
these peri metropolitan bowel waves
where the city grows and then the
uses are pushed further away from the
city and dairy spreads out and this was
the 70s so we had advances in
transportation and rail and it still
held true and then angel [ __ ] has done
a lot of work on urban expansion
and noted that
where those agricultural land values are
high enough i.e getting enough rent they
curb urban expansion that's one of the
few variables that can shape urban
expansion so sorry say that again i
didn't quite get the argument there
um
that
where
the ag land is producing enough value
it can out compete urban expansion so
you're you're not
changing it over into housing you're
able to keep those
dairies or orchards in place you know
when we're reading aristotle i kind of
sometimes feel when people raise
aristotle's name he would have made a
great podcast guest i'm sorry that he
was so long ago i couldn't invite him on
if i need if i maybe there'll be an ai
version of aristotle i can interview one
day
but when we're reading aristotle or
these people from the 19th century etc
and they're talking about cities are
they really talking about the same kind
of thing that we're talking about we now
we have 10 million person cities right
is it does it scale
that simply so that the cities of those
days were just tiny versions of our
cities or is it a completely different
kind of phenomenon
i think it scales in the sense that
those observations and the
1800s about cities impact on surrounding
lands held true even with the advent of
cars
and
uh
cities and their food supply
those are those are big issues to
national security they've shown up as
big issues and
of national security during times of
crisis we are in another time of crisis
right now
and cities are politically combustible
if you cut off the food supply very
quickly
um
more so than than other
um other issues like cutting off energy
which is still
awful right but but food supply you you
can end up with riots within days
yeah okay but i guess okay but it does
make sense to me that now that you
mention it i remember this another
factoid maybe again from your paper uh
that cities tend to be
the size or there's a maximum size which
is an hour commute
yeah but but depending on what your mode
of commuting is that could be relatively
small or relatively large so modern
cities can be bigger just because we can
commute faster
yes yeah that that is a is something
that's held true from
early medieval walled cities to cities
today you can go on google maps and you
can ask yourself if i wanted to get from
the center of shanghai to the edge how
long would it take me there's this joke
about la which is no matter where you
are in la or an hour from wherever you
want to go it could be
that may be a special case but for for
other cities that that commute time
holds which has led to some
urban designers pushing for
a 30-minute city or a 15-minute city
where you don't have to go that far to
get to all the things you need
job day care school groceries right but
then i i worry about that in the sense
that
this hour commute
seems like an organic constraint that
grows out of what human beings want to
do and it seems like the kind of thing
that is resistant to planters trying to
improve it right i mean famously if you
add more
lanes to a big highway that has a lot of
traffic on it the amount of traffic
doesn't go down because now more people
use it because it's a bigger highway yes
yes you cannot out you cannot highway
yourself out of a problem which is a
a great uh thing to realize
um
but you can you can
interleave
all of those things that people are
trying to get to
into the urban fabric so instead of
having a big dense city where you have
to travel that hour to get to green
space to relax to a park
um
you can do what copenhagen did and
uh interleave green wedges bike paths
and there's a lot of effort right now to
reconnect
urban spaces with
those more natural landscapes that
people are
constantly trying to get to
that makes sense but but i guess maybe
that's a perturbation as we physicists
would say on the sort of central
thing that we could think about which is
that there does seem to be some
uh
momentum toward centralization of the
major city functions right there tends
to be an urban core much like a cell has
a nucleus right and that's the kind of
thing that these 18th century people
were trying to explain that there's
valuable land and there's certain kinds
of people who are willing to pay the
rents for the most valuable lands at the
middle of the city
yes um
and that that forms the the heart of
these ideas of agglomeration economies
which is really what um
um
first talked about in the early 1900s
and then brought up again through
bettencourt and west's work on scale
looking at how
per capita they focus on the number of
people not the land area or the urban
morphology but
for more people you end up with more
jobs or more patents than you would
expect on a per capita basis also more
crime
but it so but it makes sense
actually sorry let me let me back up let
me just ask what that agglomeration idea
is uh is is it simply this sort of super
linear scaling that you know when when
people conglomerate in a small area
everything happens more rapidly and and
more vivaciously
it might be partly that it also might be
a sorting effect where you you have a a
group of firms and so people are
commuting long distances to get into to
work there but you can imagine with
um
in silicon valley it's it's easier to
have multiple tech firms together then
they can hire that you know
from each other and learn from each
other and compete
rather than being
i don't know somewhere somewhere else
which is why it's so hard right now
because
it's very difficult to build new housing
in a lot of communities because they
don't want new housing and as firms grow
if their cities are not willing to grow
with them
then firms start asking themselves
these hard questions about should we
relocate and if we relocate will we be
able to attract
um the the same caliber of
knowledge
yeah i mean presumably
that's an interesting thing so what i
was thinking of in my head was this plot
i think i saw on wikipedia in in
preparing for this about how
from this bid rent curve analysis
retail likes to be the very center of
the city and then manufacturing is a
little bit more dispersed and
residential is the most dispersed of all
but what what you're saying now is that
that
that's sort of a there's an economics
behind that but there's also this human
tendency to say okay i got mine let's
not let anyone else in which is which is
sort of acting as a break on the growth
of some of these neighborhoods
right right
and in some cases you get things like
jewelers row and philadelphia where a
lot of
companies that do the same thing
co-locate because they know that when
people go jewelry shopping they can stop
at multiple stores and in other cases
you get communities that say
no we don't want any competition we're
the only bookstore in town
literally last night we uh we had
delivery indian food and jennifer my
wife was reminiscing about living in new
york in the east village and said there
was like literally one block where all
the indian restaurants were so that you
knew that if you couldn't get into one
there was one right next door so you
could you could imagine why that there's
sort of different ways of thinking
you're if you're what you're thinking is
i would like indian food it makes
perfect sense for all the restaurants
that are nominally in competition with
each other to be right next door
yeah and then you have to balance that
competition cooperation
scale who's getting bigger
right right so okay so it makes sense to
me that you know there's a sort of
stratification of what happens where in
the cities but
part of me wants to historically you
know i i was a kid in the 1970s
and in the u.s at least on the east
coast where i was growing up the inner
city was where you did not want to be i
mean there's been a sea change today the
inner city seems like the fun you know
hip place to be so how do we explain
that that sort of flip of desirability
in in terms of these theories
um i think partly it's that a lot of
political will
went back into the city and to zoom
further out in the and put this in sort
of academic terms
scholars like to think of cities as
having a metabolism and they're feeding
they're feeding off of something and
there are three main schools of thought
there's
karl marx's political ecology it's
political will and that political will
was focused on inner city new york and
crime and
schools
then there's the human ecology thought
process which is focused on
resources like water
air so
and then there's the industrial ecology
portion which is focused on just raw
energy
but but all of those
think about
feeding the city something
and um and
the political process for a while was
starving cities of a funding of capital
of redevelopment opportunities and when
that shifted
inner cities were able to to rethink
themselves to build new buildings
renovate new buildings attract um
attract
uh younger families and younger families
are then moving into older buildings and
renovating them themselves as well right
um
so so there's there was some of that
happening
i mean you mentioned these three
theories uh i presume that they all
capture some part of the puzzle and then
it's not like one is right and we're
gonna discover it
no and you can imagine if you don't have
political will you can't direct a new
water system to the city or
uh you know
shift energy demand so they they're all
one and the same what they're lacking
however is that in any analogy of
metabolism you have to think about a
metabolic interface that metabolic
interface is really important to
metabolism doing its job so if you think
about
the human gut which is a great analogy
for a metabolic system
the intestines
have a surface area that's the size of a
tennis court i mean they're just big and
you need that surface area in order to
absorb all the nutrients and what the
metabolism the urban metabolism theories
are missing is this analogy of what's
the
what's that surface area for a city so
this is where the the unifying theory
that we've built and urban development
comes into play where we say well what
if
that surface area is the urban periphery
itself and if it's the urban periphery
itself then you don't want that
concentric
city
you really want a highly regards
complicated structure and that
complicated structure
helps perfuse the system with all the
nutrients it needs
um and also allows it to grow in a
branching fashion
i mean it sounds like it's almost a
mistake to think about the metabolism of
the city rather the metabolism of
the region that has both cities and
suburbs and rural areas right i mean the
city takes a lot from its surroundings
here in l.a
i don't know what fraction of my
drinking water comes from northern
california but but a lot of it
uh
but hopefully we give something back
right whether it's you know ideas or
sports teams or whatever right so is
there some
realization
that we need to be more holistic when
thinking about this
the center that i run the center for
regional change is very focused on
explicitly acknowledging the interchange
across regions and that it doesn't just
stop at a jurisdiction
but i think it's really difficult
because you end up with some cities that
have decided not to add housing or not
to grow
up or out and so they're very expensive
and
right next to those same cities are
other cities that are less expensive and
have less services and amenities and
poorer school districts and they they
are co-located with each other
because the service workers need to live
a little bit
you know near but they can't live quite
where they work and you see this in
terms of mega region commuting in the
bay area where people
can't afford to live in san francisco
and they commute two hours one way and
that impacts people in the central
valley
and and
frankly causes displacement as well
yeah whenever people are moving to la i
say like the primary consideration about
where you live who cares where you live
just don't live too far away from where
you work because then your life will be
they never listen to me but i do think
that there's a it's a real decrement to
your quality of life if you're spending
three hours a day in your car commuting
but i guess when you mention those those
constraints uh san francisco and new
york are the two cities that come to
mind where you have very very wealthy
areas
and they need
to to be adjacent to areas where people
with lower incomes can live right to
have this kind of economy are there
other places we should have in mind or
are there other places that do it more
successfully and mix people together
better
there are other places that that do it
more successfully but that
this co-location of
um
[Music]
uh slums
with with high income development is is
a is worldwide it's not just new york
and san francisco and the places that do
it better focus
on a whole lot of
social support programs
and um
and cash support for for
wealth redistribution
which gets gets outside of the whole
city building paradigm that gets at the
heart of the inequality that can happen
in cities when
you end up with these mismatched
neighborhoods and presumably there's
some uh historical path that matters as
well when i was an undergraduate at
villanova villanova is a very very
wealthy
neighborhood on the main line in
pennsylvania outside philadelphia but
there's little tiny streets with very
tiny affordable houses on them and
eventually was explained to me that's
where the servants used to live you know
200 years ago when the rich people lived
in their mansions and
maybe that is you know repurposed later
on but but gives a little bit more of an
organic feeling to how to mix the
populations together
yeah i mean there are historic uh
precedents to why certain neighborhoods
have the development trajectories they
have and some of that is
redlining denying mortgages and
loan programs particularly to
communities of color and low-income
folks and that creates these pockets
where neighborhoods
are not invested in and it's not just
the loans it's the
funding for transportation lines for
street cars which provides job access
it's schools i mean philadelphia is a
great example
your property taxes are what fund the
schools and if you're in a a lower
income area there's less property taxes
to go to the schools which shifts
how often you can renovate the school
how many teachers you can hire
which is why you get these huge
disparities with wealthier suburbs
having
amazingly resourced public schools yeah
no i think it's an amazingly huge
scandal that we pay for public schools
with property taxes but i can't get
anyone to listen to me i don't know i
don't know what the better system would
be but why in the world would you build
in that richer people have better public
schools like if they want to go to
private schools that's fine but why
should there be better public schools i
understand that
well california has solved that a little
bit with a a very complicated school
funding formula
to move away from
the the the disparities
there still are very big disparities
here in california
right so it doesn't seem to be perfect
yet but okay anyway uh off of that but
um
there's one thing i didn't want to quite
lose because you mentioned these
theories about you know the inner city
versus suburbs etc um but but those
theories are all sort of politico
economic and i think that in the 70s
when i was uh growing up through this
sort of uh feeling i think a lot of it
would have been more
the story that you would have heard
would have been a lot more about
individual preferences right the dream
was to live in the suburbs and have a
yard whereas
somehow 20 years later the dream is to
be in a high-rise apartment with a
beautiful view or something like that
and so how do we
judge that interplay of individual
preferences versus socioeconomic forces
i think part of it is acknowledging that
there's not one dream there are multiple
dreams in multiple stages of life we
lived in a condo in philadelphia and it
was great um
but eventually we wanted to have a house
with the yard
you know so
there's different stages and and
creating cities that provide for all of
that is is the trick but i also think
that
there are huge disparities in which
neighborhoods have access to green space
park equity is a big issue and part of
this gets to how we design cities we
were thinking about
building cities and urban fabrics and
access to jobs but we're not necessarily
thinking about those green spaces where
kids play where they develop deep
appreciation for nature for for
conservation for the planet
um and
that that's the piece in
the science of cities and city building
that needs to shift a little bit to
consider cities and green spaces
together
so is it a matter of
searching for
more heterogeneity on a smaller scale in
other words like just don't have a huge
swath of city that is all business
high-rises or don't have a huge swathe
of the city that is all apartment
buildings either you need these mixtures
this sort of here's green space here's a
school here's a high-rise is that a
better model to think about
it is and it's a it's a model that's not
particularly new this is a model that
jane jacobs
was a proponent of that we weren't going
to
talk about the city in terms of here's
how it should be but we were going to
organically let it grow through
accretion
and and the more difference you could
build into spaces the better that should
be celebrated that diversity and
complexity would help make it resilient
um
which which is again i think the piece
that has been
missing in a lot of these conversations
of of city development i actually at one
point asked how often architects or city
planners
use random number generators
like isn't there a tendency like we want
to draw straight lines and and do things
that way because it's orderly and we can
hold it in our brains whereas organic
growth is a little bit less predictable
and regular
i think you're giving planners too much
credit in the in the 1950s or or 40s
planners were coming out with these big
plans and this is part of the problem
because you had planners like robert
moses saying we're going to build a
highway through
the bronx and there was massive uprising
against
drawing those straight lines across
neighborhoods philly is another example
of a highway that went right through
chinatown the highway seemed to always
go straight through communities of color
and there was major upheaval and
pushback and that pushback
meant that planning as a discipline had
to completely change and planners are
now facilitators of community voices so
if the community says we want a
playground then you make a plan to make
that that playground happen as opposed
to
[Music]
as opposed to
coming top down and saying here's what
would be best it's not the the the way
the planning works now is still
fraught with problems because the people
have the time and the energy to come to
those city council meetings will then
have more say in the plan however you
can be undocumented you can be
six years old and you can show up to
city council and advocate for what you
want to see in your city plan which is
pretty beautiful it's
a more inclusive democratic process than
voting is
am i right that i read somewhere where
high-income black neighborhoods tend to
share qualities with low-income white
neighborhoods like it's not purely
economic we're there's still cultural
things that get in the way of uh of i
don't say equality because there's still
economic equality there but even within
an economic stratum there's not pure
equality
no there's not and and this is i think
kimberly crenshaw does a really great
job of talking about intersectionality
and how
um even at that community scale beyond
the individual scale there are
race class gender they're all
cross-cutting
issues in terms of who's got access to
capital
uh to and to investment opportunities
and these neighborhoods are they're not
even static right neighborhoods change
there's gentrification people get pushed
out
i've always had mixed feelings about
gentrification because to me part of it
seems like you're making the
neighborhood nicer but then again i'm
very sympathetic with the idea that yeah
but you're kicking people out who've
lived there for generations
among people who are experts in this
field is there some consensus way to
think about this
there's not consensus there there are um
this is a great question because
uh somebody was asking me okay well
catherine you have this great idea about
how we should interleave green space
with urban areas and you've shown that
that cities have a perfusion gradient
where we're all trying to reach that
edge and we want that edge but what if
the city is already built we can't
really do that
um which is a fair point but
but on the other hand you have examples
like new york's high line where you you
put this beautiful green space in the
meat packing district and it's awesome
and it's heavily used and then you see
what that did in terms of increasing
property values
which again
you know we talk about these early
theories von thunen was thinking about
land values tied only to population
density and here you have green space is
a premium
i mean this is just it's theory breaking
it's 200 years of theory breaking
because green space is so heavily valued
and it's not a use you can't extract
anything from that
so
your green space
we really value it we're willing to pay
a premium for it and that means that
low-income folks who can't afford to pay
that premium end up being displaced so
urban scholars are thinking about how to
do
amenity building that's just green
enough that doesn't cause displacement
that's got problems others are thinking
about okay well if you build an amenity
then there are other supports you could
put in place at the same time like rent
controls or
community benefits agreements which is
something we've we've worked on with
aggie square in in sacramento as the
university is moving into development in
a historically black neighborhood
we've encouraged a community benefits
agreement that can really help keep
folks in place but it's really tricky
uh
to do
amenity building
especially around green space like the
atlanta beltway is another great example
that doesn't cause those price premiums
and i think part of it is that
urban science has not anticipated that
there would be
such a price premium for green space in
urban areas it's just
has not been in
the models of city development
i had i have in mind sort of picture in
my head when you say green space but do
things like museums or libraries also
sort of fit into the same kind of
category they're very very useful
amenities but you're not going to make a
lot of money off of them
that's true
you can
you can look at how those institutions
are valued i'm i'm talking about
the price premium that's
uh captured in land value immediately
adjacent so it's one thing to be
valued as a as a community institution
it's another thing for that value to be
then captured in the housing market and
even
things like street trees end up
bringing price premiums to the houses
adjacent to them i see okay so i i guess
i got it wrong because i was thinking
that what you meant was if i build green
space there's sort of
less square footage to
generate economic opportunity but but
maybe what and therefore the price goes
up for the square footage that there is
but maybe what you mean is just that i
would rather have a view of a park than
a view of a factory or a view of someone
else's apartment building and so as soon
as i build a park the rents go up
everywhere around it
exactly it's it's your view shed
and that goes for for farmland as well
where you can do these willingness to
pay studies where people will say i'll
spend an extra dollar
in taxes every year if we preserve this
farm next door to me but you can also
look at
differences in property values when you
do preserve farmland in perpetuity so
this seems like a terrible paradox that
i'm just now appreciating like i mean i
get gentrification in the sense of
developers move in renovate apartments
and now they're nicer but now you're
saying that if i just take a
neighborhood and try to make it nicer
by planting some trees or putting a park
there
the people who who are supposed to
benefit from this can't afford to live
there anymore that sounds like a problem
it is a problem which is why you can't
just do urban development without also
thinking about uh
big policies like basic income programs
right and poverty alleviation
we're not good at thinking about those
questions very good as a society i gotta
say yes uh anyway i do want to dig into
we've delayed it too long here i mean
because you already mentioned the word
perfusion and we haven't defined what
that is it's a great
concept to be borrowing thinking about
cities and this is the topic of your of
your
research work and i want to get into it
so why does the word like perfusion come
into talk about cities
we use profusion to get at all of these
urban metabolism theories that we're
thinking about
cities being perfused with energy with
uh goods and services with knowledge as
you're you know
telling your neighbor or something and
that gets told to the next neighbor
but we we didn't
we didn't
define what that discrete unit is and
the idea behind this is that urban areas
grow in relation to the nutrients that
they're up taking and you can imagine
something very simple like a cell
growing in
a medium and that cell gets plumper and
plumper and plumper and it gets so plump
to the point where the central part of
the cell is no longer evenly perfused
and you end up with necrosis and to
avoid that what the cell will do is
elongate instead
and we
suggested that cities perhaps operate
the same way where they grow to a
certain point and then they elongate and
they branch and you can observe these
branching patterns in cities across the
us which has worked by michael baddie
and longley who've looked at the fractal
growth patterns of cities so this
branching pattern has been observed but
it
hadn't been explained quite yet and part
of the reason it hadn't been explained
is because so many theories about city
building were looking only internally at
conglomeration economies right at how
urban areas form and they weren't
thinking about how cities form in
response to their environment
and so the word profusion correct me if
i'm wrong is borrowed from like our
circulatory system
yes it's borrowed from from biology and
this is a long history of urban science
first borrowing from physics when urban
planners were
you know thinking will we just explain
how this works and then it'll work to
shifting the analogies and the the
science over to biology
uh as
cities
began to be seen less as machines to be
programmed and more as
emergent phenomena to be observed and
perhaps prodded
yeah this makes perfect sense to me
exactly that uh progression uh physics
is the simplest science it's a it's a
science for short attention span people
so it's where you start biology is more
complicated and and i can see that you
know there are physics analogies in
biology and that would then extend to
the city so
but the thing about biology right or an
organism is that it is
not rectilinear grids right we have
these complicated fractal networks
inside of ourselves like circulatory
system the respiratory system and the
profusion if i get it right is how
those systems give us nutrients so what
you're saying is that if we were
thinking about cities as just you know
who wants to live next to who or what
business wants to live next to what
business
fine but you're missing something you're
missing all of this exchange uh with the
outside world and
including the need for that exchange is
going to give you different predictions
for the shape and the morphology of the
cities sorry right especially
considering that these patterns have
held true for hundreds of thousands of
years where
transportation has
revolutionized from walking to
uh automobiles and cities have
kept within a radius of their urban edge
do we know what's it what it means to
have an urban edge is that a
well-defined thing
no it's a highly debated thing and part
of the problem is that defining what a
city is or isn't is tricky i mean take
philadelphia and new york for example
you can live in philly and commute to
new york they're not the same city
but you could argue new jersey is new
york and some people do when you ask
them where they're from they say new
york but they're not
um so
the the way that we got around that is
we looked at um
uh census designated urban areas and
those are agnostic about the
jurisdictional boundaries so you end up
with contiguous urban areas and you can
approximate an edge as opposed to
getting into the nitty-gritty of
where exactly does
philadelphia end or where exactly does
la end for that one oh my god
well l.a southern california is weird
right because like we have cities inside
of la that are nominally independent but
clearly are spiritually part of l.a yes
exactly 90 i think you have yeah
something like that okay but uh okay so
the basic idea is then like when the
city is small enough there can be
relatively easy
communication of these resources from
the periphery to the inside but when it
becomes too big you have to start
crinkling the edges in order to pull
that off is that the basic idea right
perhaps when it comes to big certain
neighborhoods are cut off from urban
metabolism from from good services from
from that
green space that is so
desired in urban centers
um
and when that happens
you end up perhaps with more inequality
i mean it seems i i can i think i can
think of counter examples like paris is
a big city that is more or less a blob
but maybe the point is that paris has a
structure that
has a lot of green space and and big
boulevards and a river going through it
and that does the job it does and paris
has been surrounded by agricultural
producing land i mean it's been able to
retain its food shed around it more so
than many other cities globally
okay that that does make sense but i
mean maybe distinguish because i i keep
thinking of
like the
roots on which energy and food come the
transportation routes or the the the
motion of water or electricity but you
keep mentioning the green spaces which
is like a human need how do those fit
together is one more important than the
other or are they both like flip sides
of a similar set of requirements they're
important but in different ways and i
think this is again where our science of
cities needs adjusting so if you take
bettencourt and west's theory of scale
they talk about three assumptions for
city building that cities need to be
optimized which you could argue cities
are not optimized um that they're
space-filling
uh networks but then they don't use
they don't use roads and they don't use
sewer lines which is interesting um
sorry and part of that is that roads
they are not bettencourt and west don't
use that in court and west they base
their scale
approximations on human population total
number
um and the networks they say are social
networks so part of that is that you can
have a roadway but it doesn't
necessarily predict use because places
parks for example have a lot of use a
lot of social interactions
not a lot of roads hopefully yeah
and a lot of commercial activity around
them a lot of civic activity
a lot of business as well so
those transit lines are important but as
as we talked about earlier you you put a
highway through
a neighborhood it destroys the
the urban fabric
so it's not
um
it's it
the highway is not analogous to our
blood vessel system it's just not
am i am i correct in thinking that
there's an increasing number of major
metropolitan areas that are either
getting rid of hot big highways or
shunting them around or putting them
underground
you are correct and some major cities
like stockholm are burying entire ring
roads
bigger bigger projects than boston's big
dig
and those projects what they're they're
doing which is pretty clever is
they're
pushing those highways underground and
then building uh selling the land that's
on top
for more housing development commercial
business and creating park space
and part of this feeds into this
uh public health effort that has come
about
because of kovid really where this has
been a knee-jerk response to
the the last few pandemics where we've
realized gosh we need to create more
green space in cities for health reasons
not just
being able to eat uh and not get covered
but also recreation and mental health we
acknowledge that green space is very
important to our health and our stress
levels which is why
cities across the us have closed roads
during covid
have
created outdoor dining areas and it's
part of this broader trend to
excavate
roads from cities to remove them to make
the urban fabric more enjoyable it seems
like sometimes we human beings are
pretty slow on the uptake like
the fact that i live in los angeles and
the weather is beautiful year round and
there's very little outdoor dining
compared to places like paris where that
is not true right
and but we are like you just said we're
sort of discovering the possibility of
it and hopefully that improves things
but why is it taking so long for people
to realize that it's kind of fun to be
outside
i think a lot of our our dominant theory
building in cities was centered on cars
and car access and if you didn't have
enough highways running
through and to your city then you
wouldn't get all of those commuters
who were living in the suburbs so there
was this real idea that you should push
urban development
out further away and you should have a
low density fringe and this is again
where this perfusion idea flips all of
that completely on its head if green
space creates such a price premium then
you want high density development on
that urban edge so that it's not limited
to the wealthy few
uh and you're capturing more of that
value that's being generated
not how we've done development in the us
yeah so you want more contrast where you
have both green space and high density
development cheek by gel
yes exactly and scandinavian cities uh
do this um very well right so they're
excellent examples
and
again this is gonna be my uh desire to
make things simple and physicist like
but
is part of the
conceptual shift to go from thinking in
terms of space in terms of you know how
big the city is to terms of time like if
you have different ways of traveling
that's kind of what matters like what
matters is how long it takes you to get
there not how many miles away things are
so as we get different transportation
methods uh the structure of the city is
going to change along with it
yes
exactly which is forms the basis of the
the 15-minute city or the 30-minute city
or these other efforts to um
cure what's called food deserts so lack
of a grocery store in a neighborhood to
get all of the amenities close enough to
where people live so that they can
live work eat and enjoy
in this in the same area without having
to travel
two hours to get into san francisco
during rush hour to work and then two
hours back home so i'm sure that uh
you're in a field where there's plenty
of data in some sense maybe there's not
enough i don't know you'll tell me but
there's a lot of cities out there doing
a lot of things
just as one question that comes to mind
is is there are there clear differences
between cities with good public
transportation and subway networks and
cities without uh
do cities sprawl a little bit more when
you can get places on the subway
places that have subways tend to not
have built those subways unless they
already had a
high level of density
to begin with okay and then um
places that are investing in subway
systems tend to encourage more density
because they get more value out of this
huge public investment that they've
spent so there's this correlation it's
all correlations
okay um so if you if you decide as a
community that you're going to invest in
in the subway system or in a you know
then you're you're also going to invest
in
in more density to support that is is
how that
should go it doesn't always go that way
and here's part of the problem so
um nationally we don't have an urban
agenda
um okay the state of california where we
are both located and many other states
make promises about how they're gonna do
development but
it is up to the local city and the
county to come up with their own plan
and each of those smaller jurisdictions
makes their plan
but until recently
we haven't really had data
infrastructure to
make visualize all of those plans stitch
them together see how they're
interacting with their neighbors and we
haven't had the ability to read across
all of those plans with natural language
processing for example
so there's a lot of work to be done and
looking at how all of these
emergent areas are planning for their
futures and to stitch it all together
at the at the state level and at the
national level and other countries don't
always operate that way so
um a lot of european countries have a
centralized planning agency and then
they tell their regions what they need
to do to build
so it's
it is top down
that is met with how to do that bottom
up but
is there data about how well that works
i mean again the planning is very
complicated this is a feature of complex
systems right there's lots of unintended
consequences and therefore planning is
hard but
we tend to do stupid things in the
absence of planning also so can we can
we say how useful planning is are we
getting better at it
i like to think we're getting better at
it for for example um
when we look across plans in california
big issues around social justice are
more and more making their appearance in
city plans that are tackling systemic
racism
historic redlining practices that are
building in social support programs and
emphasizing environmental justice and
environmental justice has been a a goal
at the state level for a long time but
those
communities haven't risen to that
challenge as much as they perhaps
could have
they haven't met that that mandate
head-on and there's no agency
in california
that is empowered to read all of these
city plans with the exception of
housing and community development which
looks at just the housing element of
plans so they're not looking at
green space planning um they're not
looking at um
hazard planning is a huge issue
nationwide because if you don't have an
up-to-date hazard plan
you're not eligible for fema payout if
disaster strikes and with 40 percent of
the population across the us
experiencing
a major climate hazard
just last year
this is a really big problem but but
without this data infrastructure and
ability to read all of the hazard plans
and ability to help communities come up
to date particularly cash-strapped
communities um
we're in trouble
some of these sounds like you know
self-inflicted problems or these
problems that human beings set up for
either bureaucratic or political reasons
and therefore i'd like to think that
they're solvable they're not intrinsic
to the situation uh but
it does seem like it would require a
certain amount of political willpower to
make those changes it would and and this
is local political willpower that is
required and there are plenty of
examples of communities that have that
willpower and are making those changes
and differences
and the the research community has a lot
of work to do and has done a lot of work
and bringing client climate science to
the forefront and
um
and
making amazing models about who might be
impacted and how and
here are different suites of policies
like project drawdown has this excellent
suite of policies that are all priced
out
and ground truth for communities to
choose from
uh but then the rubber hits the road
with that local plan right right you got
to make it happen yeah and and speaking
of data and fitting to theories um the
perfusion discussion about how like a a
crinkly kind of uh heterogeneous
structure is going to be
better both for getting the resources in
and out and making people happier with
green space so and presumably those
effects grow with the size of the city
so is that something we can see in the
data but
i mean i guess it's confused by the fact
that even if it would be better
if you were crinkly that doesn't mean
the city grows that way so i'm not even
quite sure what question we should be
asking here
uh the city does grow in a very
branching pattern as as batty and
longley have pointed out with their
fractal cities work and
an angel [ __ ] as well with the urban
expansion project has looked at this
globally
but
what has not yet happened is that
intentionally acknowledging we grow in a
branching pattern that's a good thing we
need to perfuse urban fabric with green
space and part of that is because
our theories of city building have just
not
factored in
the amenity values of green space and
urban areas for example that von thunen
bid rent
curve that we talked about in the
beginning
that that he was only focused on
farmland and when that theory got sucked
up into urban theory you ended up with
these
graphs where you have the central
business district fetching a really high
premium and then it just tapers off to
the edge and a really nice smooth line
that's not how it works
um there's not a smooth line there's a
big bump at that urban edge because
people pay a premium to live on the
urban edge
okay so there's a there's a mismatch
between the very simplified theory and
the testing of that theory and what's
happened and there's an adjustment that
needs to be made there
i mean on all this talk about green
space uh
are we making a mistake by lumping
together all the different ways that
spaces can be green i mean presumably
there must be better and worse kinds of
green space they used to live in chicago
where apparently a brilliant decision
had been made early on that they were
not going to allow too much development
right on the lake right so the lakefront
was a was a wonderful resource for the
city uh they made the opposite stupid
decision for the river the river was
completely ignored
what are the good kinds of green spaces
that we've learned to uh work especially
hard to preserve
or build that's a great question because
and again i really love the analogy of a
city as a coral reef with all the
diversity of uses
you can have a river that has been an
industrial
waste
zone
for a century and you can clean it up to
the point where people can swim in it
which is what's happened in copenhagen
and what used to be a scuzzy nasty canal
is now a highly sought after
redevelopment opportunity so
you can you can shift
a natural feature into an amenity or you
can trash it
right
but but specifically you know our
when we say green space are parks that
is just sort of big general purpose
things the best thing or does it make
sense to have specific you know uh
baseball diamonds or whatever are there
are there worries that certain
individual preferences are gonna
ruin the good intentions of building
green space if someone really wants a
polo grounds and there's not really
anyone around to play polo
these are all heavily debated issues you
can go into any city hall across the
united states and people are debating
should this be a pickleball court or
should we have another tennis court
um
or should it be a parking space the
other favorite thing in city council
meetings and i think it's up to each
community's preference
if you're talking to wildlife
conservationists
they would say you want contiguous urban
spaces to allow wildlife corridors um
to to be able to to move around so that
you don't end up with wildlife trapped
in urban environments and roadkill for
example
um
that's definitely a big deal here in l.a
yeah
but but okay i mean that reminds me that
we sort of
didn't give enough attention to the
parking space phenomenon uh or the role
of cars more generally you did touch on
it you mentioned it
um
should we try to get rid of cars more or
at least should we try to reserve more
city spaces for
purely pedestrian use or is that kind of
a little bit utopian and cars are always
going to serve an important role for
people in the middle of the city
there's been some really interesting
work done on where cities create
pedestrian malls
and
you would think that they would they
would just thrive everywhere which is
what a lot of cities thought and um and
they don't you need a critical mass of
people who are already walking and
biking using that space like like that
in order to close the road and keep it a
vital
walk bike area and if you don't have
that vitality to begin with
then you you can't just create it out of
nothing so as with all things it's a
it's a game of accretion and
hardcore incrementalism uh to shift away
from
from certain uses and add other uses it
really happens that you can just slam
something down and it works i like the
idea of hardcore incrementalism that's a
great phrase a little bit of attention
there but but okay then just to wrap
things up i mean there's a lot of great
ideas here and there's a certain
uh worry that i have that we can have
all the great ideas in the world and not
implement them as a big fan of parks and
rec uh i know that these town meetings
don't always uh lead to great decisions
what do you see as the future of cities
in in the us abroad everywhere like
clearly they're more and more important
for the world are we going to be getting
better and better at
creating useful urban environments or
are the
countervailing pressures going to
overwhelm any good intentions we might
have
there are countervailing pressures but i
am an optimist and i believe that
generally people want to live in a
really nice place and they're going to
try and make that so
what we don't have is a lot of data
infrastructure for a plan so we don't
have a you might have a zoning map for
your city you might not know how to read
that so it's inaccessible in that way
and then your zoning map dead ends at
your city and isn't stitched together
with the 89 other cities that make up la
so creating these big data sets and then
educating the public on how to interpret
them is really important and then
there's the plan piece which is where uh
we've created a portal that's just for
california right now but we're going to
expand to other states where advocates
can look up whatever they care about
and it could be parking lots it could be
mountain lion habitat it could be a safe
routes to school and they can see how
other cities have planned for those
similar features and then
pull those policies or talk to those
cities
about how to
do better so that i think that that
level of transparency will help with
advocates who are trying to move the
needle in their own cities
that's good i think that's optimistic
but tempered with
a healthy dose of realism right there so
catherine brickley thanks so much for
being on the mindscape podcast thank you
so much for having me sean
[Music]
you